hi I'm Miguel and I am going to talk
about Cuban CI I knew command-line tool
to manage multi cluster ingresses I'm
going to talk about what it does why is
it useful and how it works but before I
get started I do want to point out that
Cuban CI is not an official supported
product it's an exploration we want
people to try it out and see if it's
useful secondly as I talk about Cuban CI
I'm going to assume knowledge about
kubernetes and kubernetes ingress
if you've used kubernetes ingress with
Google cloud load balancer to create l7
load balancers you can now use cube mci
to do the same for multiple kubernetes
clusters doesn't that sound awesome
let's see how it works I talk use cases
for cube M C ie a low latency and high
availability let's look at this diagram
on the right we have two clusters
cluster one in GCP zone US central 1a
and cluster two in GCP zone Europe West
3a service who exists in both these
clusters now if user Alice from
California wants to need service foo we
want Google cloud load balancer to send
that request to cluster one similarly if
user Bob from Berlin since the same
request we want that request to go to
cluster two this ensures low latency if
cluster two goes down we still want user
Bob to be able to read service foo in
that case Google cloud load balancer
should send that request to cluster one
that ensures high availability
now how Cuban CI works is it has a cube
MC I create command maybe you can give
it a name your kubernetes English
definition as English Tamil and a list
of clusters when clusters not Yama if
you run this command cube MCI creates
the English in all the cluster
in this case in both cluster 1 and
cluster 2 and then configures google
cloud load balancer to send the traffic
appropriately to pass it the list of
clusters you can give your existing
queue conflict or in future we want to
integrate with kubernetes cluster
registry while this is an high-level
overview you can also take a look at the
code it's open sourced he can go to
github and you'll see all the code there
you can try it out and start
contributing to the code as well but
let's take a look at a demo for this
demo I have two clusters one in US and
one in Europe I have my zpq config file
which has information about both these
clusters so this is the cube config file
that I'm going to use with cube mci I'm
using a zone printer app for this
example what the app does is it prints
the GCP zone that it is running in I've
created my zone printer app in u.s.
cluster and now I'm going to create the
same app in my Europe cluster so that
the same app exists in both once we have
the setup ready and now ready to use
cube mci to create my load balancer
let's look at cube mci help first qmc I
help prints all the available commands
there's create there is delete this get
status to get the status of an existing
English and help and the version of the
tool so let's look deeper at cube MC I
create we look at the help for cube MC I
create this tells me I need to pass a
load balancer name and some flags GCP
project is a required flag the ingress
spec is a required flag and cube config
is required so let's try it out let's
run cuban CI create
i'm going to
name my load balancer soon printer lb I
have an English spec and I use ZP cube
config it prints that it created the
ingress in both those clusters then
created health check backend service
neural map target proxy forwarding rules
it's creating all the resources required
to configure Google cloud load balancer
once it's done I can run get status
command to see the status of my load
balancer to get the status I passed the
name and the GCP project it is I and it
tells me yes such a load balancer exists
and this is the IP address the load
balancer is spread across two clusters
cluster uswest and cluster EU West as I
wanted GCL be Google cloud load balancer
takes some time to configure once it's
done we can hit this IP address to
ensure that it's working as expected to
do that let's hit that IP address from a
VM in my u.s. cluster as expected it
returns that the request was served from
us best one eh let's do the same for
Europe cluster and in this case we
expect it to be served from the Europe
zone
if also from Europe zone so this shows
that our setup is working as expected
this is great you should try it out and
we'd love to get your feedback positive
or not any feedback is appreciated thank
you